[Music]
with the arrival of fall and Colder
Weather staying up to date with your
immunizations including booster doses is
all more important to protect yourself
your loved ones and the more vulnerable
people around you as well as to protect
our health care workers
achieving another milestone in Canada's
covid-19 vaccine rollout Health Canada
has authorized a second bivalent umicron
targeting covid-19 vaccine the Pfizer
b-o-n-tech EA four five vaccine for use
as a booster dose achieving yet another
milestone in Canada's covid-19 vaccine
rollout Health Canada has authorized a
second
ovarian Omicron targeting covid-19
vaccine the Pfizer Bon Tech ba4 ba5
vaccine for use as a booster dose
these updated by valent vaccines Target
Two strains of the covid-19 virus the
original strain and the Omicron strain
this means that there are now two
bivalent Omicron targeting vaccines
available in Canada
the moderna by the vaccine was
authorized last month for people 18
years of age and older and the Pfizer
bivalent vaccine is authorized today for
people 12 years of age and older
the national advisory committee for
immunization has also released updated
guidance on fire booster doses to
reflect the authorization of these
vaccines
Nasi now recommends that people 12 years
of age and over who are eligible to get
a booster dose this fall receive a
bivalent vaccine these vaccines will be
will boost our immune system and give us
better protection against Omicron
it has if it has been six months or more
since your last dose it is time to
recharge your immune vaccination immune
system and get a booster dose
this is especially important if you're
65 years of age or older or you are at
higher risk of severe illness from Kobe
19. it's also important to protect those
around us and our healthcare workers
if you have recently received a fall
boost to those with an original mRNA
vaccine you do not need to receive a
bivalent Omicron targeting booster at
this time
since that's because the original
vaccines continue to provide good
protection against serious illness and
hospitalization
both bivalent vaccines will boost your
immune response and are expected to
offer better protection against omifron
ICS
vaccines now approved in Canada modernas
and pfizers both provide excellent
immune response and enhanced protection
against the Omicron variants
if it's been more than six months since
your last dose it's time to recharge
your immune system and get a booster
dose in addition an important reminder
that with kids now back in school and
the flu season fast approaching we
encourage all parents to get their
children six months to 8 to 11 years of
age to be vaccinated with the primary
series of kobit 19 vaccine so that they
can bet they can be better protected
while on the subject of children and
therefore before I turn to Dr Tam let me
say that I share the concerns from many
parents about their ability to find
infant and children's analgesics
products and understand those concerns
over the summer months there has been
unprecedented demand for these products
and increase supply has found it
difficult to keep pace
we are working hand in hand with
manufacturers and suppliers to keep
increasing Supply to meet increasing
demand and to ensure that families have
access to these important medicines
I personally spoke to several
manufacturers including Johnson and
Johnson Elon and farmer science as well
as to associations of Pharmacists and
pediatricians to reiterate their urgent
need to collaborate to find both a
short-term and a long-term solution to
this sort to this shortage so parents
can have the medicine they need to take
care of their children
as a half of infants and children
remains our top priority all options to
solve this shortage are on the table in
health Canada will provide regular
updates on this situation
[Music]
there was an unprecedented demand for
these products and the increase in
supply
has not kept pace
we are working hand in hand with
manufacturers and suppliers to continue
to increase Supply to meet demand and to
ensure that families have access to
these essential medicines
I personally have spoken with several
manufacturers including Johnson and
Johnson halion and Pharma science as
well as Pharmacy and pediatric
associations to reiterate the urgent
need to work together to find immediate
and long-term solutions to this shortage
so that parents may have the medicines
they need to care for their sick
children
the health of infants and children is
our top prior already and all options to
resolve this shortage are on the table
regular updates on the supply situation
will be provided by Health Canada thank
you oh and I like to turn the floor over
to Dr Tam
thank you very much
nationally the covid-19 disease
indicators including weekly case counts
have increased in recent weeks which may
be an early sign of for resurgence
despite the usual Regional variation
virus transmission is occurring across
the country
the Omicron late summer wave appears to
have declined very gradually before
picking up again after only a brief
leveling off in many areas with the
ongoing transmission Hospital Trends are
still elevated although Critical Care
Trends and deaths remain at a low level
as our contacts and potential exposure
increase with more time spent indoors
this fall and winter we could see
further increases in covid-19 activity
at the same time we know that immunity
from vaccination and or prior infection
decreases over time therefore the
national advisory committee on
immunization recommends getting a
covid-19 booster dose six months after a
previous covid-19 vaccine dose or SARS
covert infection to maintain up-to-date
protection
across Canada as more people go beyond
the six-month time lapse since their
last vaccine dose or infection
population immunity is falling and
leaving us all less protected with our
up-to-date vaccination to help prevent
serious illness many people could land
in hospital due to cover 19. covid-19
vaccination may also help reduce the
risk of developing post-covert 19
condition or long covered
as of early September Canada's boosted
those coverage has remained quite low
with just half of the population
vaccinated with an additional dose
however
with over 82 percent of the population
having completed their primary series we
have a great Foundation to build on to
once again become a world leader for
up-to-date vaccine coverage
with Canada's recent authorization of
the Pfizer biotech common Naughty by
Valen vaccine we now have two bivalent
covid-19 vaccines booster formulations
as options for restoring protection in
people age 12 years or older
both the Pfizer and moderna bivalent
vaccine formulations Target the original
virus drain and the highly infectious
Omicron variant likewise both bivalent
vaccines are expected to boost immunity
against Omicron variants and broaden the
repertoire of our immune response to the
SARS cov2 virus
nevertheless if you recently received a
boost dose of an original mRNA covid-19
vaccine you did the right thing when it
comes to covid-19 in fact protection the
most important thing is to stay up to
date with your protection and evidence
continues to show that Canada's original
covid-19 vaccine formulations provide
good protection against hospitalization
and severe disease
so if you've been recently received a
primary or booster dose with an original
covid-19 vaccine you do not need to be
reimmunized with a bivalent MRA vaccine
at this time
it's also important to note that in some
cases Canada's national advisory
committee on immunization recommends a
shorter interval of three months may be
warranted this could include cases where
there is a heightened epidemiologic risk
such as immune vulnerable individuals or
elevated levels of virus in the
community and your health provider or
local public health authority can help
guide you in maintaining optimal
protection with covid-19 vaccines
in the coming weeks seasonal influenza
vaccines will be rolled out across
Canada
so it's good to know that influenza
vaccines can be given at the same time
as covid-19 vaccines to people over five
years of age however while this may
increase convenience it increased
convenience for some if you are due for
covid-19 vaccine or boosters now it is
recommended not to wait
so I'll give a quick update on monkeypox
Canada continues to closely monitor the
monkey pox outbreak as of today a total
of
1411 cases have been reported nationally
with just five additional cases reported
over the past week so the outbreak has
slowed considerably
in Canada the use of precautions and
risk reduction behaviors particularly in
outbreak affected populations and
settings have been crucial to control
the spread and now time for
implementation and adaptation of
vaccination programs to reach those at
higher risk
to date over 86 000 individuals have
been vaccinated with at least one dose
of the invermium vaccine across affected
populations in Canada
given adequate supplies Nasi recommends
pre-exposure vaccinations should be
offered as a to those primary series
with at least 28 days between doses to
individuals at highest risk of infection
the public health agency of Canada
continues to support Province and
territories in their ongoing efforts
including through strong Partnerships or
communities to maximize vaccination
coverage
encouragingly recent evidence from the
United States outbreak demonstrates that
the incidence of monkeypox infection was
14 times lower for people vaccinated
with a first vaccine dose compared to
unvaccinated people at similarly high
risk concluding that people eligible for
monkeypox vaccination should get
vaccinated as soon as possible
specifically the U.S study looked at the
genius vaccine which is the same
formulation as the invermium vaccine in
use in Canada
so as we go into the Thanksgiving long
weekend
let's do our best to safely Gather in
person to celebrate all of our efforts
and recommit to not lose the gains we've
made
although no individual layer of
protection is perfect when used
consistently and together vaccine plus
layers can provide excellent protection
against covid-19 as well as many other
infectious diseases we may encounter
in particular improving indoor
ventilation where you can and continuing
to wear a good quality face mask
especially in poorly ventilated or
crowded settings are some of the most
effective personal protective measures
you can take to reduce your risk of
exposure and spreading disease
that's what covid-19 in particular Dr
Ted Rose the director general of the
World Health Organization recently
offered the encouragement that we have
never been in a better position to end
the pandemic but we're not there yet the
end is in sight and we can get there if
we all step up and seize the opportunity
now to reach and maintain our best
protection getting your covid-19
vaccinations up to date with Omicron
targeting bivalent vaccine is a key step
in seizing this opportunity thank you
merci migrich
disease indicators including weekly case
counts have increased in recent weeks
which may be an early sign of fall
Resurgence
despite the usual Regional variation a
virus transmission is occurring across
the country
the Omicron late summer wave appears to
have declined very gradually before
picking up again after only a brief
leveling off in many areas
with the ongoing transmission Hospital
Trends are still elevated although
critical critical care Trends and deaths
remain at a low level
as our contacts and potential exposures
increase with more time spent indoors
this fall and winter
we could see further increases in
covid-19 activities
at the same time we know that immunity
from vaccination and or prior infection
decreases over time
the national advisory committee on
immunization
recommends getting a covid-19 booster
dose six months after a previous
covid-19 vaccine dose
SARS cov2 infection in order to maintain
up-to-date protection
across Canada
as more people go beyond a six-month
time last lapse since their last vaccine
dose or infection population immunity is
falling and leaving us all less well
protected
without up-to-date vaccination to help
prevent serious illness many people
could land in hospital due to covet 19.
the vaccination
vaccination may also help reduce the
risk of developing long covid
19 conditions as of early September
Canada's booster dose coverage
has remained quite low with just half of
the population vaccinated with an
additional dose however with over 82 of
the population having completed their
primary series
we have a great Foundation to build on
to once again
become a world leader
up-to-date vaccination coverage
with health Canada's recent approval
of the Pfizer biontec
by valent vaccine we now have two
bivalent covid-19 vaccine booster
formulations as options for restoring
protection in people age 12 or order
older
both the fives are in the modernist
vaccine formulations Target the original
virus strain and the highly infectious
umigrant variant
likewise both by valent vaccines are
expected to boost immunity against
Omicron variants and broaden the
repertoire of our immune response to the
SARS cov2 virus nevertheless if you
recently received a booster dose of an
original mRNA covid-19 vaccine
you did the right thing
when it comes to covid-19 protection the
most important thing is to stay up to
date with your protection
and evidence continues to show that
Canada's original covid-19 vaccine
formulations provide good protection
against hospitalization and severe
disease
so if you have recently received a
primary or booster dose with an original
covid-19 vaccine you do not need to be
re-immunized with a bivalent mRNA
vaccine at this time it is also
important to note that in some cases
Canada's national advisory committee on
immunization recommends that a shorter
interval of three months may be
warranted this could include cases where
there is a heightened epidemiologic risk
such as an immune vulnerable individual
immunity
or elevated levels of the virus in the
community
your health provider or local public
health authority can help guide you in
maintaining optimal protection
with kobit 19 vaccines
in the coming weeks
2022-23 seasonal influenza vaccines will
be ruled out across Canada it is good to
know that influenza vaccines can be
given at the same time as covid-19
vaccines two people over five years of
age however while this may increase
convenience for some if you are due for
a covid-19 vaccine dose or a booster now
it is recommended
to wait
have been reported nationally thank you
with just five new additional cases
reported in the past week the outbreak
has slowed considerably in Canada
use of precautions and risk reduction
behaviors
particularly an outbreak affected
populations and settings have been
crucial to control the spread and allow
time for implementation an adaptation of
vaccination programs to reach those at
highest risk
today at over 86 000 individuals have
been vaccinated with at least one dose
of the imamine vaccine across affected
populations in Canada given adequate
supplies Nasi recommends pre-exposure
vaccine Nation should be offered as a
two dose primary series with at least 28
days between doses two individuals at
high risk risk of infection
public health agency of Canada continues
to support provinces and territories in
their ongoing efforts including area
through strong Partnerships with
communities to maximize vaccination
coverage
encouragingly recent evidence from the
U.S outbreak demonstrates
that incidence of monkey pox infection
was 14 times lower for people vaccinated
with a first vaccine dose compared to
unvaccinated people at similarly high
risk concluding that
people eligible for monkeypox
vaccination should get vaccinated
as soon as possible specifically the U.S
study looked at the journey vaccine
which is the same formulation as the
immune vaccine in use in Canada as we go
into the Thanksgiving long weekend let's
do our best to
safely Gather in person to celebrate all
our efforts and recommit
to not lose the gains we have made
although no individual layer of
protection is perfect
when used consistently and together
vaccines plus layers can provide
excellent protection against covid-19 as
well as many other infectious diseases
we may encounter in particular
improving indoor ventilation where you
can and continuing to wear a good
quality face mask especially in poorly
ventilated or crowded settings are some
of the most effective personal
protective measures you can take to
reduce your risk of exposure and
spreading disease
19 in particular Dr Pedros director
general of the World Health Organization
recently offered the encouragement
we have never been in a better position
to end the pandemic
though we are not there yet the end is
in sight and we can get there if we all
Step Up
sees the opportunity now to reach and
maintain our best protection
getting your covid-19 vaccinations up to
date within
Omicron targeting by valent vaccine is a
key step in seizing this opportunity
thank you merci
okay we'll start with Excuse me we'll
start with questions in the room one
question one follow I'll start with
Emily Bergeron from LA Press Canadian
um
there are either thousands or millions
of doses that have expired that were not
used in time and here we're looking at
another new vaccine what will come of
those
prior generation vaccines what are you
going to do to avoid any Mass waste of
vaccine doses
thank you there are many goals in the
context of our framework the first thing
is to make sure that Canadians have
access to the best possible vaccines in
a context where covid-19 is continuing
to cause harm
in individuals families healthcare
workers and all other patients other
than covid-19 patients anyone who has a
hard time getting access to diagnoses
treatments and and want to take care of
their health our number one goal here is
the security and quality of vaccine
Supply another goal is to make sure that
all of this is done in an effective and
responsible way when it comes to these
doses that already exist we want to
manage that well with respect to people
who will be getting a booster dose the
current
uh vaccines
there are people who are going to be
making that choice to follow that
original recommendation now as to
managing
the bivalent vaccine doses public health
agency of Canada we'll make sure
that if there if we can expect that
there will be doses not used by
Canadians that those doses can be
offered to countries abroad or or
managed in such a way as to make their
failability make sure that their
availability lasts for longer period
we know that some people will choose to
get vaccinated very quickly others will
choose to wait a few months maybe to to
the new year or later in 2023.
responsible management of vaccines does
require spreading out Supply and
administration over several months
as a follow-up you mentioned this in
your opening remarks
acetaminophen for Pediatric uses
[Music]
one of the solutions that had that was
raised even actually this week
was
criteria with respect to labeling in
other words
have products come in that might be in a
foreign language the question was asked
of Dr Sharma earlier on
that Avenue has already been taking can
you clarify where things stand at this
on that front and sir I'll start by
saying again this is an important
concerning issue for us our families
that there are young families that are
not having access to analgesics for
their children it's really critical in
many cases and that's the case not only
in a context where it reduces fever pain
and discomfort but it also means
children can avoid Landing in emergency
rooms and it also means they don't have
to say necessarily in hospital settings
when families have access to these
analgesics for their kids it's good not
only for obvious reasons for individual
health for those individual children fit
it all so protects the Health Care
system as a whole prevention having
children who end up in hospital
this is information that pediatricians
are sharing with us family doctors are
saying to what extent it is important
for families and children to have access
to these drugs the other thing is that I
personally over the last few days heard
from
suppliers producers manufacturers and
Pharmacists and I was told I was assured
that an increased accelerated production
rate was going to continue in order to
meet the increased need that we've noted
over the last few months and which
likely could continue over the next few
months what we're noting and this is
from the Pediatric community in the
Healthcare System we've noted over the
last few months that there has been a
significance
a demand because there are viruses that
are serious calculating that perhaps
other at other times might not meaning
that our children are getting sicker
than usual and we are concerned for the
coming months because we know the flu
other respiratory viruses and certainly
covid-19 will continue to impact our
children's health so industry
pharmacists are assuring me that the
increase in the last couple of months in
terms of their increased Doses and
availability will be something that they
will be pursuing over the coming months
what I've had discussions with about
with Partners is that there are
emergency orders available to facilitate
production and import
products that are usually not necessary
in the country these emergency
regulations are available can have
access to them when required they know
this and it includes some flexibility
when it comes to labeling however on
that front of course labeling
let's say unusual has to be at least
sufficient and in context where it's
also provided with additional fact
sheets for families so that when they
get access to these drugs have access to
the information both official languages
the kind of information that would be
required for them to be able to use this
into medication it's from the Toronto
Star
hi um Ministry clothes is picking up on
my colleague's question what have the
companies told you about when this
shortage is going to end
this shortage has been there for quite a
few months already
and the main reason is talking to
pediatricians uh what Physicians and
other Healthcare professionals have seen
over the last few months is our children
have been more sick
through all sorts of respiratory viruses
and other conditions that were not usual
before covid-19 and therefore they have
obviously needed more of these
analgesics and therefore the demand for
such drug has significantly increased
over the last few months fortunately
Supply and production have also
increased significantly depending on
manufacturers the suppliers how to
increase between around 50 percent and
sometimes has even doubled or tripled
but that has not been enough to address
the the significantly increase in demand
for analgesics they have assured me that
the supply will keep increasing over the
few the next few weeks and months to
restock the inventory that has been low
over the last few months and weeks and
obviously to prepare for the increased
demand that we are going to continually
that we're going to continue to see over
the next few weeks and months as
covid-19 the flu and other viruses
impact more the health of our children I
have also reminded them that there
exists the emergency regulation that
they can call to and use if that is
useful for them to increase the ability
to have access to active ingredients to
facilitate the effectiveness of Supply
chains to import quickly and more
efficiently whatever drugs may be needed
to
supplement the domestic production of
those drugs and any other type of
regulatory agility I have reminded them
that this is available they just need to
ask so I have also asked the pharmacists
Physicians and producers and suppliers
to work to work even more together to
make sure that families and children
have access to the drugs that they need
they will continue to need
if these if regulations exist that they
could use what's your understanding of
why they're not using them and why
haven't they used them in the last six
months if this has been a shortage
dating back six months they have used
some of them but there will be more
there are there there are more that they
can use uh they obviously know what's
most effective and useful for them some
of these regulations with at this
particular time be I understand of
little use for them but they know these
are really a graduation exist and I have
asked them to be very proactive and very
quick in letting us know how we can
support their use and their availability
to them and therefore to the benefit of
our children and families
Kim Vermette from Radio Canada
um
vaccine the Pfizer vaccine would be more
effective against uh sub-variants than
the moderna one could you tell us about
the efficacy of this new vaccine you're
there are people who really want access
to that particular vaccine what we're
hearing from experts in fact there are
two experts right here in the room today
is that we now have two vaccines to
specifically designed to fight Omicron
both very good
news experts are telling us that um
of course shares some distinctions I
mean when it comes to these subvariants
but the important thing is to fight
against Omicron both vaccines are both
good and superior to the existing
formulation now with respect to the
existing formulation
it's by valence option is very good as
well
it's even
pre-bivalent but it's even better now
that we have this bivalent vaccine Dr
new Dr Tim if you had anything to add
thank you Minister not much to add other
than to say that
these two vaccines you're looking right
now at a bivalent vaccine it contains
something to strike against the original
variant and now against the uh
given all the evidence we have both
provide good protection against Roman
crime and the original
if it's been more than six months since
your last dose or your last infection
thank you very much another question for
you Minister
promises are responsible for the
distribution of vaccines do you find
provinces are doing enough to promote
this the booster Sean I I do hear your
concern
expressed about the coming fall season
are you concerned about it how things
evolved and so yes I am concerned from
what I'm hearing from the experts that
are are telling us two things
that the coming months the coming weeks
will be critical
when it comes to covid-19 infection and
all
consequences this can have for people
and for health care workers who are
already
quite tired
who want to try to
deal with the backlogs in terms of
surgery cancer diagnosis and illnesses
for which these Physicians really did
not have enough time
the other thing that experts are telling
us is that we have vaccines that are
very effective and they work even better
now given these bivalent vaccines in
today's announcement furthermore what we
know is
that if we do better use make better use
of these vaccines in Canada we will be
able to significantly reduce the
hospitalization rate that we will
observe towards the end of the fall in
the early 2023 one simulation done by
public health agency of Canada was to
say if you went from 60 to 90 rate of
third dose then you would Reduce by 80
the rate of hospitalization that we will
see at the end of The Fall season and
early winter that's 90 fewer people that
would be ill or health care workers it
would be severely impacted and all the
other people that are are going to need
care in our hospitals we are lagging
behind as far as the third dose is
concerned compared to other countries
the last few weeks have been encouraging
we've noticed that in Quebec and
elsewhere
vaccine was available
um people have realized that these
vaccines are available we're going to
have to accelerate the access to this
information but also actually access
to the vaccine itself we want to
simplify people's lives we want these
vaccines to be accessible to people
people don't have much time do we go to
the schools do we go into these mobile
clinics
um Healthcare centers into companies
businesses these would be ways to
facilitate vaccinations and protect
everyone in the coming weeks Glenn
McGregor rctv news
uh Mr diclow your government's been
promoting booster shots since Sometime
Late last year and yet as Dr Tam said
only about half of people have gotten a
booster and the people getting a second
booster a fourth shot is something like
13 now you're here promoting a vaccine
that could be used as a fifth booster
doesn't seem like this is going very
well what is the problem here why are
people not getting boosted is it is it
because your government is communicating
a mixed message you're you're getting
rid of Border measures you're getting
rid of mass mandates on on uh trains and
planes and at the same time you're
trying to get people boosted why is this
not working
a as we know we've done really well with
two doses uh B we are lagging behind
other countries in terms of third doses
uh C the situation has improved over the
last few weeks we've seen an uptake in
uh in in in in more dorses and in both
equally importantly importantly in the
number of people being up to date in
their vaccination and D we need to do
better and much better over the next few
weeks and months if we want to protect
everyone and protect our healthcare
workers as well who need help so we know
for instance that if we are we were to
increase the number of people in the
relatively short time uh vaccinated with
the third dose among Idols from 60 to 90
percent we would Reduce by 90 the number
of hospitalizations that we will
otherwise see in the end of the fall or
early 2023 90 reduction in a number of
Hospital realizations that we would
otherwise see end of the Fall beginning
of 2023 that's a big impact that's a big
impact obviously protecting Canadians
against the severe impacts of acute long
covet against the long-term impacts of
long covid which is an issue to which
we'll come back in shortly because
important work is being done by P hack
and and others within the government to
explain to Canadians the risk of long
covid many many Kines are aware of that
already but there is a serious thing
happening
in Canada and elsewhere in the world
around Long Covey then vaccination
against covid-19 helps both protect
against covid-19 infections but also
protect against the long-term impacts of
being infected with uh with infected
with long with Kobe 19. so these are all
reasons all the important reasons to be
doing better over the next few weeks and
months and we'll be working
increasingly collaboratively with
provinces and territories to see how we
can increase the value of the way of
doing that but also the accessibility
and the ease the ease of having access
to those the strong and valuable
bivalent vaccines
those are statistics that are not always
compelling to everyone sometimes
examples are more important yesterday
the leader of the opposition went on
cfra radio here in Ottawa and said he
had been twice vaccinated which of
course is the minimum requirement for
him to step into the House of Commons uh
wondering what kind of example do you
think that sends and would you say
something to him about that about
whether he should be more uh outspoken
about advocating for booster doses I
think we should all be uh and I will
turn to Dr Tom in a second I think we
should all be advocating uh for that no
we all gain in having more people around
us being up to date in their vaccination
status uh we all gain because that
reduces infections it reduces severe
cases of of covid-19 it reduces long uh
long covid it also protects our health
care workers who are in a crisis and
have difficulty addressing uh needs
others and then those related to
covid-19 but let me turn to Dr Tom
has an obligation to mean as an elected
official to
to set a better example I think we all
we all had an obligation in particularly
elected members of parliament who have
access to type of advice that Dr Tam has
been providing now for some time now
it's not as if
we are not aware of the importance of
being up to date in terms of vaccination
members of parliament have access to
that information on a daily basis you
know through all sorts of of of of
exchanges but Dr Tam
um obviously you have a a role a
responsibility to be perhaps more
balanced than I would be when I speak
about members of parliament but if you
can speak briefly about the the
importance for everyone to be um to be
up to date in their vaccination status
yes so getting the first two those is
obviously very important we and it still
provides uh uh protection against
serious outcomes but ever since Omicron
appeared that was the moment when all
experts the vaccine experts the national
advisory committee on immunization has
recommended an additional dose because
it's simply not enough in the omicon era
to have two doses
and now we learn over time of course
about waning immunity as time goes on
which is why we're recommending boosters
if you haven't had one in the last six
months and now with updated boosters
you've got even more
um opportunities to increase your
protection and also broadening the
immune response so I do think that it's
important not just for individual
protection but to protect each other and
to protect against the health systems As
Leaders we all have a role to play We're
examples that people follow and I think
it's important to do so I do think
individual stories are very important
and um and many
um it's been very helpful to have people
um have have helped answer questions and
have actually spoken out quite frankly
about the experience of having very
prolonged symptoms for example after
having had an infection many people
after a whole year or even two years
haven't recovered their previous normal
state of health
so again as I meant to do closely we
will be obviously looking at our data
and boosting our understanding as well
as our recommendations on Long coveted
service significant impact on the
economy on our labor workforce and
certainly on the health system
I'm gonna excuse me I'm gonna use
moderators privilege to ask a question
from this uh this spot uh Minister Duke
Lowe I haven't heard anybody really
talking about the deliveries of these
new vaccines they're authorized uh when
are what when are we actually expecting
to get deliveries of ba45 how many are
we expecting to get and is this going to
impact how many doses of the ba1 and the
other vaccines that we're getting
good uh two answers first on moderna
second on Pfizer on Medina we currently
have about 10 million doses of the
bivalent vaccine that was authorized
earlier in September on Pfizer there
will be about
2.8 million doses delivered around next
week and a total of approximately 11
million before between now and the end
of the Fall
and is it I mean nasty is now
recommended that the you know who should
get it but is it still going to be
distributed based on what prevent
provinces are asking is there is there
going to be any change in how it's being
distributed uh because of the bivalent
nature
I don't think the the
um
the mechanical
work of of uh you know making those
vaccines available to provinces and
territories that's going to change
um do we know if the bivalent
formulation needs different
um ways of being transported and stored
in the earlier formulation
a very
prolonged relationship and collaboration
with Province and territory over the
last many months at figuring out vaccine
distribution of course every
jurisdiction will have a chance to get
access to both of these bivalent
products they are of course submitting
their needs and requirements as we speak
certainly as new products are coming
along but um
we've we've worked at a quite an
intricate way of looking at the
provincial demands
I don't see any hands raised on Zoom so
that'll conclude today's press
conference